welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Vossen HBO's succession final season is
posed a question who will succeed the
Throne of the media conglomerate waste
star royco how depressed will this make
us about the state of the country or
just the state of HBO which is now just
called Max
now if you don't watch succession you
totally should if you don't have time to
watch the first three seasons you can
check out my recap of the first three
seasons and watch the episodes of season
4 on my ax but tomorrow morning from
here forward because it will be spoiling
major plot points from the entire series
but just the first Nine episodes of
season four because I haven't seen the
series finale episode yet as of this
taping but this final season a
succession has been a night fight among
the members of the Roy family after
Logan Roy's death and season 4 episode 3
Logan's children Kendall Roman and
Siobhan or shiv are left jockeying for
control of the company All in This Dance
with Gojo Tech head Lucas Madsen the
boys trying to block his buyout so they
can stay in control of the company
should have tried to help it so that
he'll put her in charge of the company
but all three of these kids have
skeletons in their closet that could
disqualify them Kendall of course killed
that caterer and was part to the
cover-up Roman sent dick pics to Jerry
that she very recently threatened to
release in episode 7 and she didn't
remember pressure that witness and waste
our sex abuse Cruise scandal at the end
of season two so I began this season
assuming Tom womsgans was going to come
out on top but another character is
crept in from the Shadows to make a
strong claim for the CEO job and he
could see him coming from a mile away
cousin Greg Greg the [__] egg
now again I have not seen the finale
episode yet I mean I could be totally
wrong about this but I want to give you
all the clues setting up why Greg might
win succession and if not in the events
in the finale episode maybe at some
point in the hypothetical epilogue
future of this fictional world because
remember the series opens with Graham
join him at the bottom working at the
way star Theme Park puking out of the
eye holes of waystar's mascot what a
perfect metaphorical opening image for
this future CEO the Mickey Mouse of this
world pukes spewing out of his eyes the
entire pilot episode is from Greg's
Outsider point of view accidentally
getting roped along with the Roy family
events establishing its ability to just
appear in a room whenever an incredibly
important decision is being made
throughout season one Greg forms an
alliance with Tom who bullies Greg and
forces him to destroy damning documents
about waystar's Cruise Scandal if this
is all the hero's journey for Greg this
would be his Call to Adventure because
Greg smartly makes copies of some of
those documents and he later uses them
to try to Blackmail Tom but when Tom
tries to destroy these documents in his
fire pit Greg snatches a few of them out
of that fire pit and then later uses
these documents as leverage to briefly
align with Kindle at the end of season
two at that press conference when Kindle
turns on Logan so in season three while
Tom is worried about going to prison
over all this Greg's position just Rises
and Rises at the company and when his
grandpa you in Logan's estranged brother
gives Greg's inheritance to Greenpeace
Greg Sue's green and in the season three
political conference in Virginia this
wins in the support of a bunch of
alt-right Bros the guys who will sweep
Jared menk into Victory throughout the
primary process so when season 4 begins
Greg has risen in stature more than any
other character in the series in season
4 episode 4 a possible addendum to
Logan's will is discovered with some
penciled in notes next to Greg's name
you're an addendum of miscellaneous
matters in pencil
with a question mark nevertheless dad
may have said
he wanted me to take over and so then
maybe the natural conclusion might
perhaps be I'd be his number two nice
track set up the possibility that even
Logan had his eye on this kid during the
Norway retreat in episode 5 Greg
surprisingly has good Intel about Gojo
that the other big players don't have oh
so there is a kill list oh yeah I have
it on good authority there's a kill list
eight nine names it's evolving Greg
consistently proves that he is thinking
big just saying yeah in case you guys
want to sling some ideas around just
within the safety of the Quad the quad
yeah the Quad Squad the the Roy Patrol
the the old team the family
and when Tom tries to impress Matson
with his only card to play belittling
Greg Greg pivots immediately and proves
he's actually read a recent article in
The Economist and he looks well less
idiotic than Tom but that's really all
he needs to prove in this moment in
episode six it's Greg that Kendall uses
to orchestrate a critical deep fake of
Logan's video recording to convince
investors that living plus will be
successful I'm convinced that the living
plus real estate brand can bring with a
cruise ship experience to dry land and
double the earnings about Parks division
okay that's not cool it's really well
edited and in episode 7 Tom makes Greg
fire dozens of waystar international
employees over Zoom a rite of passage
for every CEO and during the election
Eve party notice how Greg takes note of
how tired Tom is maybe a little oh man
maybe drink a coffee if I drink a coffee
then I won't be able to sleep later
think Greg yes sleepy sleepy Tom has
been an important figure in these latter
episodes in episode 8 Greg tells Tom
that he spent the past evening partying
with Matson drinking things that aren't
drinks dancing with an old man and then
drop some key and tell hey man I got the
impression
do you know about Matson with chef and
they're sort of like their their
business Alliance agreement and then
later in this episode Tom asks where's
my coffee Tom I don't do coffee anymore
no Greg
Greg I have to be clear I have to if I
get drowsy
and I Miss call Colorado
instability right but instead Greg tells
Tom that he got him his cocaine do you
want some of what you asked for yeah hit
me
but this is not a not a thing okay it's
not going in a book not going in a book
a call back to the fact that Greg was
the leak who talked to that Logan Roy
biographer back in season two and led to
that whole bore on the floor moment when
Tom covered for Greg throughout the
series Greg is a contact that they've
used to score drugs like in season two
ew
dude
uh that is it's from a connection
in the park park Coke yeah I'm doing
Park Coke are you [__] kidding me
yeah no that's the worst Coke I've ever
had so back to sleepy sleepy Tom I think
Greg might be intentionally giving Tom
bad coke Park Coke or just Coke laced
with a downer that has made Tom
lethargic during these important
decisions in the election episode Tom
begins tonight saying he makes the call
but you don't you don't make the call I
make the call and by the end of the
night he sleepily surrenders it hey guys
it's not my call water is like the
vegetables of drinks it's important but
you know it isn't really fun but with
air up drinking enough water every day
goes from being something you have to do
to something you want to do air up uses
your sense of smell to make your water
delicious there's no sugar no calories
No Junk making air up a healthy
alternative to sugary flavored beverages
it's just plain water in here but Arab's
revolutionary hydration system lets you
choose what flavor you want from a
variety of tasty flavor pods so here's
how it works I got water in here and I
got an orange flavor pod you just plug
that flavor bot on you hold it up to
your mouth and you breathe in through
your nose as you Sip and something
magical happens in your brain to make it
taste like orange so you sip you don't
tip and the bubbles carry the scent to
your nose and your brain just makes the
flavor personally I really like this
orange Aid flavor it makes me feel like
I'm having a sports drink but without
all that extra calories and I drink way
more water than I used to and that just
makes me feel better than I used to to
reinvigorate your relationship with
water and get an air up bottle of your
own just click the link in the
description and use code nr20 to get 20
off your order today remember back in
season three Tom was in the process of
adjusting to low quality food to prepare
for prison life you know that Rasputin
would take a dose of arsenic with
breakfast each morning to build up his
tolerance uh Rasputin reference the
first of two this season because later
than season three finale Kendall tells
Roman in the car that Madison's gonna
take him to seller and Romanov him but
Rasputin was an advisor to the Russian
Romanov family Rasputin staked his way
into this royal family and was later
killed by the Romanov cousins Tom is
Rasputin The Outsider who wormed his way
into the Royals and gets taken out right
at the end Greg is the cousin in this
election episode the infamous Wasabi
scene chekhov's Bodega sushi right by
Darwin's laptop we see Darwin slide it
with his finger and that finger grazes
the Wasabi right before he touches his
eye and then Greg pours live in Lacroix
in the eye making it worse so that
Darwin is unable to provide any
credibility to the Wisconsin call on ATN
and the election gets swayed to Menken
now I don't think Greg is a secret
genius or anything but he is a more
truly American success story a dummy
tall white guy with the right name who
just happens to be at the right place at
the right time while other more
competent people have to drop out and
soon enough this guy is the last man
standing really the American success
story is that all the European powers
just took each other out during the
pollyonic wars yet we should point out
that Greg does make moves like it is
Greg who rats out shiv to Kendall that
shiv was going behind their backs to cut
a deal with Matson leading to the
pivotal realignment during that election
Night episode in episode 9 Tom freaks
out over how a rival newspaper covers
that decision at ATN so who gave them
the timeline
well a lot of people know a lot of
people don't want to go to the Hague for
war crimes there's a great graphic of
Darwin but think of this diminishes my
role notice how throughout this Greg
keeps checking his phone since he was
that Laker in season two to the
biographer it was probably him who gave
the timeline to the newspaper and
deliberately in the newspaper diminished
Tom's role in it so then at the funeral
Greg wants Roman to make an introduction
between him and president-elect Menken
so long as Greg can stop Ewan for making
a speech but Ewan goes up anyway and
pushes off Greg allowing Yoon to make
this powerful eulogy that completely
throws off Romans playing tribute to his
father and Roman crumbles in this
episode but notice how Greg compliments
you in after this it's a good hard take
so just to recap Greg knows Tom ordered
him to destroy the documents and
diminish Tom's role at ATM and he kept
the receipts Greg blew a tackle on you
and at the funeral so Roman could get
sacked Greg brought down [__] by
snitched on her on Election night and
throughout all this Greg has been
endearing himself to Matson off-screen
and we never talk about this but Greg
might know about Kindle in the caterer
Kendall had been hitting up Greg for
drugs all night and we forget how it was
Greg who directed Kendall to that
caterer some guys smoke weed around the
back I think might know
you little Machiavellian [__]
I see you Greg Greg has all the receipts
so if Greg wins it would just make far
more sense than bran winning in Game of
Thrones at the end of that as Greg would
be a perfectly satirical statement on
America where the blandest cream always
Rises to the top and it's really the
doofus tall relatives who inherit the
earth hey subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive and you can support us
we're grabbing some merch at
nerdright.shop and check out our newest
series on this channel Tommy tours in
each episode your travel guide Tom tours
will take you on a journey exploring a
Fantastical location from one of your
favorite nerdy properties the series
premieres this Thursday so be sure to
check it out here's Tom torch to tell
you more do you want to take your family
on an unforgettable vacation have you
looked at a map or Globe lately and
thought boring then you need to take a
tour a Tommy tour Tommy tours is a new
weekly infotainment experience where I
Tom tours will take you on a tour of the
universe's hottest locales tours you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you